[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour or so then we will
see what's making the headlines with the
sun's political editor
harry cole and the political editor of
the daily mirror pippa creer
first of all let's check out the front
pages then the mirror leading on today's
announcement that people
in their 20s are now being invited to
have their first covert jabs
on the front of the metro a report by
mps say
says the nhs is chronically understaffed
with many workers suffering from high
levels of stress or burnout
the guardian says rebel tory mps are
considering
legal action after their attempt to
overturn cuts to the international aid
budget
was blocked tft reports that g7
countries are planning to focus on
amazon's
cloud computing business to ensure the
company pays more tax
the daily mail leading on the news that
the first man convicted of murder
using dna evidence has been told he can
be released from
jail and the telegraph says brussels
could start a
trade war if boris johnson overrides the
brexit agreement
so that northern irish shops can keep
selling
british sausages
so harry cole pippa create are here with
me now and welcome to a few lovely to
see you both
and let's start with the the metro shall
we which reports
um that the nhs is probably as we know
chronically understaffed
with many workers suffering from high
levels of stress or burnout
to be expected i guess and the problem
with pippa is
that it runs hot anyway you throw a
pandemic on top of it
and it's extremely difficult working
conditions for everybody
yes this is a report on the uh health
and social care
committee inquiry which has been led by
jeremy hunt who of course is a former
health secretary
and the big problem for the nhs really
is as you say that it was
kind of always quite close to the wire
anyway with how much it's been able to
cope with every winter when we've
had um flew out breaks we've seen
waiting lists
shoot up and then we sort of get to
summer and the system manages to catch
up
um and then we're back to the same
problems again every winter and it's not
just under investment i mean
there has been a huge amount that has
been a huge part of the
problem um in the last decade but it's
also about
structural changes which the nhs really
as such a monolithic organization
probably needs to
to undergo and um the problem with the
uh the health and social care committee
is particularly focusing on is the
uh the impact of the pandemic on top of
everything else
on nhs workers who of course have been
on the front line and we've seen
we've seen study after study suggest
that they have had really quite a
profound impact on their mental health i
mean how could it be anything other than
that really when you consider
what some of the frontline workers have
had to have to go through
over the last year and not only caring
for terribly old people
under really strange circumstances but
also their own health
being put at risk by doing that and
sometimes under resourced in terms of
the
lack of ppe and so on early on and you
know there's a there's an employment
crisis when it comes to the nhs anyway
a staffing crisis and the pandemics only
made it worse so
you know this would at least bear some
of the the concerns that the government
will
will inevitably have over the this
future of the nhs and how urgent it is
that those problems are addressed
and you know there are literally
thousands of vacancies aren't there
harry um you know is is there something
the government can do
for example what many have deemed the
derisory pay
offer for nhs staff could that be
adapted
i think the excuse me i think the
structural problems
as pepper pointed out there um the
pandemic is exposed and
and made worse um go far deeper i think
than tinkering around with percentage of
pay
um there's a health white paper in the
offering um
which i think will could send alarm
bells to a lot of public health
officials that
the you know after coming through this
bruising pandemic they really want for
the next couple of years
um arguing about nhs structures and
and things like that or do they want the
investments and the money to get on with
the job
um obviously you know since boris
johnson came into power he has
dramatically increased nhs funding but
it's clear that money uh as as many
politicians will say
is never quite enough it's uh it's um
it's how it's spent that needs to
need to get to that i do think it's
amusing that jeremy hunt does keep
popping up
uh with these great uh with his great
reports um given that he had he was the
man that was running the health
service for the better part of a decade
in the run-up to this pandemic
and i you can't help but think perhaps
some of these uh
investigations he's doing these grand
committees he's holding these
interrogations of his previous
successors
sorry um could be a little bit to do
with um
sort of getting his excuses in early
before the inevitable
big public inquiry scheduled to start
next year
um perhaps might find um the nhs and uh
public health england especially
somewhat wanting
in the run-up on on on pandemic
preparedness
and um there's only one man in the frame
really that's going to be um
you know facing questions over why we
weren't ready for this
yeah i mean that's interesting isn't it
he also wanted to be prime minister
it would have been interesting to see
what a former health section would have
been like
in contrast i think um to what he did
a little bit like gordon brown a little
bit like gordon brown who became the
prime minister after
uh in the height of financial crisis it
would have been fascinating you know to
be like well
who's been in charge for the last ten
years yeah i mean northern rock feels so
long ago doesn't it to be fair um
so let's stay with the pandemic then
pepper and go inside the metro um this
is the the great rush which is still
underway isn't it back from portugal
which
goes from from green to to amber
overnight
yeah you can't really be anything other
than to feel anything other than sorry
sorry for all those people that have
gone out to portugal for their holiday
and
uh you know probably much much needed
and
looked forward to holiday and then uh
the portugal was put on
the amber list removed from the green
list and they've had to rush back and
inevitably that means that in some cases
the flight
uh costs would have gone up and uh those
that are
right after the 4 am deadline tomorrow
morning
will find themselves having to to
self-isolate quarantine
as well as undergoing tests on their
return um i mean it does raise the
more general question doesn't it as to
whether we should be
really thinking about foreign holidays
european holidays this year at all
and whether we should instead follow the
advice that some of our senior
politicians have enjoying a great
british break and
you know personally i can understand the
allure of a bit of sunshine although
i've spent the last few days in scotland
where i have to say you know ended up
seeing a bit of a tan um so it's not all
bad it's not all bad in the uk
otherwise but the serious point here is
of course that the government has
not exactly excelled itself when it
comes to its border policy
during covet it took a long time to
close down borders it's the big question
of course about the delay
over putting india on the red list which
resulted in
the indian variant the delta variants we
now call it arriving in the uk
and then we are looking at the prospect
just as we did last summer of having
countries
chopping and changing on and off the
list depending on
both their not just obviously the the
rates but sort of political decisions as
well about copies and the risks
of new variants being brought here um
and that will make
very many holiday makers very upset um
brings us back
again as i say to whether we should just
get our tent site and go
go camping the league district instead
they're all booked aren't they and
they're so expensive i mean there's not
there's not enough availability in the
uk to cater for absolutely everybody
you know back garden if you're lucky i
think for some of us um meanwhile let's
go to the daily telegraph
jabs are working as intensive care
admissions slump
all of this feeding into decision day
for the government
ahead of june the 21st harry when are we
likely to find out
what are the factors they're looking at
and what's your best guess on what will
happen
in two weeks time
to pretend that's quite a question
hopefully when we're back when we're
back here time next week we will be in
the clear
um pippa and i will be down g7 uh
for the great global summit uh next week
and then
the entire uh westminster press pack
will jump on the train back to
westminster for back the
day job of talking about covid so
they're waiting for the last possible
minute to make the decision
which is going to be next monday
afternoon um the
the the data that proves definitively
one way the other
could take a few more weeks to come uh
whether you know whether hospitals do
uh whether the job has broken that
crucial link between hospitalizations
and cases case rates are going up
australization rates
are currently flat but as we know from
our epidemiology epidemiology 101
over the last year there's a lag of
about two to three weeks on
hospitalization
so if you think about three weeks ago
case levels were incredibly low
then the indian variant came along sorry
delta variant came along and that starts
to tick up now it's now back up to
quite serious levels uh if you're going
purely on case numbers
but hospitalizations are remaining flat
now in a week's time
will we have enough of a picture to know
that that is definitively
case lots of people in government say no
boris johnson's on the side of the
people saying
let's just wait and see where we are in
a week's time but crucially he has given
businesses
a week a week's grace to prepare for the
listing of social distancing hopefully
touchwood the relaxing of mask rules um
you know some changes perhaps the back
to work order
i suspect uh i smell fudge in there
and it won't quite be the full grand
unlocking
we want i think there will be some
restrictions lifted uh in two weeks time
and now it's next week
but i think what we'll see is a lot of a
lot of suggestions that perhaps you know
while you might be able to order a drink
at the bar
and social distancing you know you're
not gonna be fine six thousand pounds or
not wearing a mask on the train perhaps
you will be recommended to
so there's room for movement there
there's a there's a room for a fudge
and just that crucial question is if you
do delay a couple of weeks
really if it means you know 10 more
million jabs going into arms
over those two weeks and a definitive
picture emerging of the data that
says actually you know it it we all know
one way the other
is two weeks at the end of the world i'm
not sure it is
okay interesting we as you say we'll all
stay tuned
uh monday afternoon i think you said
didn't you for for that um meanwhile of
course the g7 as you mentioned
uh both of you heading to cornwall um
and this whole issue of foreign aid
and the budget is is it embarrassing do
you think before the g7
um when they're talking about these very
issues pippa
on friday and onwards yeah it i mean it
absolutely is i mean this is sort of the
crux of what you know this summit is
going to be about
how the world recovers from the pandemic
and
you know detailed announcements on
things like contributions to
international vaccine supply to kovacs
for the global system to distribute
vaccines
um amongst developing countries and
britain is the only country
which this year is um is cutting its
uh its development budget and of course
the government would say
that the pandemic means that um the
financial situation is different from
how it would be any other year and um
you know this is the temporary cut but
it's not not committing
i have to say to uh really stating the
the
um the full spending uh next year
they're going to wait and see
currently um but it's really
embarrassing when you have you know
the other leading economic powers in the
world jetting in
and all the focusing on britain and boys
johnson being very keen to
you know sort of talk up britain as a
global power and
influential and yet here we are during
during sort of the biggest humanitarian
crisis of our generation
and we're not prepared uh despite the
fact that we have a much more
um solvent and powerful uh economy than
many many other countries to to stick to
what was in fact a manifesto pledge
and of course the tory mps lots of them
obviously see it this way too
and despite boris johnson's stonking
majority are threatening to rebel
and while the vote which we look like
likely to have tomorrow is not a binding
one
uh plenty of those tory rebels are keen
to put the pressure on
and to make sure that they do get a
binding vote at some point if they don't
it'll be an environment for the
government um in international eyes
yeah we'll see what the likes of theresa
may jeremy hunt damien green etc
we'll have to say about that uh we will
stay tuned to that too
okay i'm itching to itching to i can see
uh still to come though the united
states has approved the first new drug
for alzheimer's in 20 years
we will be talking about that after the
[Music]
break
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview i'm joined by the sun's
political editor harry cole
and the political editor of the daily
mirror pippa career welcome back to both
of you
harry let's go straight to the guardian
um a picture there of
a young man who's finding himself being
talked about by the
highest you know politicians in the land
tell us more
well uh ollie robinson obviously uh his
debut uh performance for
england somewhat overshadowed by
suspension now for
tweets that emerged that he made when he
was 18 years old
daft yeah offensive rubbish
but has it sparked a an ethical debate
about whether you know
comments made on social media should be
enough to light your career forever and
face potential ruin imagine if every
single comment any one of us had ever
made
age 18 down the pub was recorded and
then brought back at the
what should have been the proudest day
of his is his career you know it's
enough to to send anyone around the bend
the prime minister's weighed in on this
it's a culture war um
way that he does is he's tuned in with
the uh you know he has an ear to these
sort of stories
last season sort of weighing in on
churchill statues and things like that
and the prime minister said look yeah he
thinks this is a bit ridiculous these
are the words of a teenager
um the guys issued a groveling apology
but probably rightly so and that
should really be the end of it now there
seems to be a bit of a
wonderful for them or wonderful for
others when it comes to this
it tends to be if you are a uh
white young male you tend to get treated
at a much harsher
level than perhaps if you were a young
female taker
labor mp zara sultana uh
wrote some absolute filthy vile
rants against jews on her social media
and what did the left do did they cancel
her no they made her a labour mp
um she was the same age she was she used
the same you know the same line i was a
teenager it's stupid i don't believe
these things now i'm sorry
and she's been allowed to you know have
a glittering parliamentary career
whereas you know there is a real call to
end this cricketer's you know
professional life and i think you know
we need to make a make a judgment call
on these things and you know at the
moment it seems to be very unfair
yeah we will no doubt talk more about
that um i'm sure there are other
thoughts um about how offensive what he
wrote
even though he was young were we run out
of time for now but we will see you very
shortly won't we
both of you thank you very much lee for
now